I got to hear Stephen Hawking speak at
the Royal Astronomical Society meeting
in London in 1995 and it was back when
he couldn't he couldn't speak for a very
long time so he wasn't able to actually
speak in real time but he could move his
fingers and he could move his eyes and
he could type on this very special
keyboard which the uh ex-husband of his
current nurse at the time had invented
that's a whole other story I can
recommend a book by my friend Charles
seif called Hawking Hawking and it was
sort of the business of Stephen Hawking
and I uh he could answer one question it
would take him about 10 minutes to
answer a question someone asked him in
the audience Professor Hawking you're
rumored to be the most brilliant man
alive and yet you've written this book
that almost no one besides you know a
younger Jordan Peterson perhaps had red
cover to cover
um why did you write this book and he
answered in his computerized synthetic
voice because my daughter needed to pay
for college